[Music]
joanna is with us in montana hi joanna
welcome to the ramsay show
hi
nice to be here good to have you how can
we help
yeah so i want to build a home on my on
my land
but i'm wondering if going with the
construction loan
is a good idea especially since i have
no credit because we're debt free
okay what's your income
yeah it's around 90k
and that's my husband i i i work at home
what's he do
software he's a full stack developer
okay great do you guys have any money
saved joanna
um so we have three months worth of
money saved we had a rough year last
year so it kind of depleted we had
six months
and then now we just brought it back up
to three after
uh
having a rough year what what's a rough
year what happened
uh he lost his job for a year
for a whole year
which was kind of really unexpected does
he do contract work
no
um
no
he he has a regular work as a salary
did you work from home
um he didn't at the time but now he does
okay
and where are you all living now you're
living on the land or what
no we found a temporary place that so we
bought a mobile house gutted
because renting was hard to find rent
and renting was expensive
and so my husband fixed up the whole
thing while he wasn't
working
and so now we're that's the reason why
we're debt-free because now we're living
in a three-bedroom two-bath mobile house
and is that on your phone
nope we're renting the lot oh okay
unfortunately we weren't able to move it
to our land okay where are you gonna
what are you gonna spend on the house
you're building
we were thinking around 300k
and we're thinking yeah at about
1500 square feet no not a huge house
okay
but yeah with materials everyone's
telling us that you know it'll be more
expensive
okay in order to get a construction loan
you would need a blueprint
that has been appraised
by an appraiser
uh the bank that you're getting the
construction loan mortgage company
you're getting construction loan can
help you with that
and you will have to have a contractor
building the property
building the house
okay they don't loan money to people who
just think they might want to build a
house
and have never done it before okay so a
licensed contractor a blueprint an
appraisal
very detailed financial package
and then your you would qualify at your
local credit union or bank for a
construction loan even if you don't have
a credit score if you've got a steady
job you've got this piece of property
that's paid for what's the property
worth
um more than 100k yeah okay so you got
the effectively a 25 down payment
in other words you'd have a 400 000 deal
if you put a 300 000 house on a 100 000
piece of ground right
yeah and that'd be a 25 equity position
from day one so they'll take a lien
against your farm
and then they will dole out the money to
the contractor on a schedule
construction draw schedule
based on completion points as the house
goes up when the house is completed
you would get a
permanent regular mortgage that pays off
the
construction loan that's called the take
out loan and you will need to rearrange
your again the mortgage company or the
bank that'll help you with this they'll
probably help you will get your
permanent loan as well because you have
to have what's called a takeout letter
how are you going to take out
this construction loan
and you're going to take it out with a
new permanent regular mortgage
all of that lines up as dominoes and you
can build now
how long is it going to take you to save
300 000 if you don't
quite a few years
yeah
i mean if you say 50 a year out of 90
it's gonna take you six years
yeah it's true
so
that's that's the numbers that are
running through my head now if you take
that out and you get out of a permanent
construction loan and then you viciously
attack that permanent mortgage after you
move in and you pay it off in five or
six years that'd be wonderful wouldn't
it
yeah it was as long as he's making 90 or
more and i if he's in tech world he
should be able to continue to do that
yeah
rachel went through building a house it
wasn't using a construction line a while
back but it is a detailed process it's
not something you just walk into and go
oh i want to put a house over there
yeah no there's there's a work yeah
you'll have a part-time job
joanna in that process but it's fun but
it's great yeah and it's and i think
it's exciting for you guys and with the
numbers and everything you guys have
worked hard to
be debt free and to be in the position
you are and so yeah making the step
forward i think is i think is great
okay so does that mean you guys think
it's a good time to build right now
because
no no not now but you're not ready now
you don't have a blueprint you don't
have a contractor you don't have an
appraisal you don't have any of this
lined up
i mean you're gonna you're gonna break
ground in next spring
maybe in the fall but i would probably
wait till spring
and let some of these lumber prices and
other things continue to calm down
lumber's back down but some of the other
stuff's not labor there's a serious
shortage on still in most areas
okay
yeah i mean but you got a lot of work to
do to get ready to break ground in the
spring
yeah
well how do you know what order to do
all these things like i i did call a
contractor
then they can help you start walking
through that uh get in touch with
churchill mortgage and see if they can
do a loan there in montana if they can't
find your local credit union talk to
them about a construction loan and a
permanent mortgage they'll help you get
the appraisal contractor can help you
get the blueprint
but you're gonna have to have all of
that you can't just say
i think 1500 and i think that's three
thousand i heard that's what i heard it
cost that's that doesn't work for
getting a loan they're not gonna they're
not loaning that person money that does
that
you gotta have like airtight business
case for this whole process whether
you've got a credit score or not
you've got to do all of that and the
land helps her
in that case because she owns it but for
a lot of people and 100 debt free help
sure yes yeah yeah absolutely but a lot
of people that want to build don't have
lands right to build you have to roll
the land into the deal yep and then that
becomes harder now you're talking about
a down payment issue right when you do
all that and that rolls in as well
so um that is a question i've been
getting
quite a f well at least on social media
okay on instagram is yeah for the new
new construction home buying is it a
smart
time
to build a house that's
there's a lot of people asking that um
i'm probably going to build one next
spring
but i'm not you are yeah but not today
yeah
i was going to ask you where i want to
ask you on the air
well i haven't figured that part out yet
i didn't know but uh well i mean i you
know we moved we moved out of the big
house yeah and we're living in a a nice
home but we had planned a bill when we
were yeah i knew that yeah
middle all this craziness we're not
gonna and it really i thought you all
were gonna take like three years just to
like do nothing i'll just
announce it to you right here on the air
so there you go but the uh um anyway
it's exciting good good for you
the point is lumber has stabilized i
think labor will smooth out by spring
it's still there's still a labor
shortage in general on construction so
construction's a little bit wacky wonky
still and i think it's going to be for a
little while longer
but i think most of the supply chain
crap will be behind us and that stuff
and i think we'll have a more normalized
environment and i kind of think the
economy is going to be a little slower
and so builders are not going to be
quite so snooty
uh about like they're doing you a
freaking favor or something you know
which is the way they act right now or
particularly acted six months if they
can yes
because they can like six months ago
they're doing you a favor or something
and i don't need them doing me a favor
and i'm building oh we know that dave we
know that